(bright upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the "Addy Hour",
I did wanna start off today
just acknowledging all of our listeners,
all of you who've been listening
over these last few weeks,
I definitely appreciate the
notes that people have sent,
it's been really encouraging to hear
how encouraging these
conversations have been for you,
how things have resonated with you,
what you've learned from them,
for the inspiration as well
and so I just want to acknowledge that
and thank you for all of your support
in these conversations so far.
Today I'm really excited,
we're gonna be jumping deep
into this conversation
at the "Intersection of
Mental Health and Faith"
and today it's one of those
where we have four unique
individuals in the room,
so I'm a little bit curious
to see what's gonna happen
when we have a pastor, a
psychiatrist and a theologian,
a social worker and a neuroscientist
altogether in the same space.
I think that's a conversation
that could go a lot of
different directions
but I think it's gonna be really
fun and informative for us
to really dig into these
topics and conversations today.
So with that, I'd like to go ahead
and welcome our three guests,
the first is Michael Walrond
Jr., also known as Pastor Mike,
Pastor Mike is the senior pastor
of the First Corinthian
Baptist Church in Harlem,
he's a prolific and sought
after teacher and preacher,
a visionary, a cultural
architect and a game changer.
Pastor Mike has lots of accolades
that he's accumulated over the years,
too numerous to list here
but I did want to mention
that in 2015 Mayor de Blasio
did name pastor Mike as the first chair
of the New York City
Clergy Advisory Council.
And Pastor Mike has also been involved
in a lot of different
initiatives in the community too
that I just want to highlight,
in 2012, his church
launched the Dream Center,
which provides over 25
completely free programs
to the Harlem community, to
its members of all of all ages,
races and backgrounds.
In 2016, he also opened the HOPE Center,
the Healing On Purpose
and Evolving Center,
which is the first faith-based
mental health facility
in Harlem.
So we're deeply just honored and thankful
for the work that he's
been doing in the community
over the years
and grateful that he's here
to join the podcast today,
thanks so much for
being here, Pastor Mike.
- Thank you for having me.
- Of course.
Our second guest is Dr. Green,
Dr. Lena Green is a
clinical social worker,
a psychotherapist and a
fatherhood practitioner
who currently serves as
the executive director
of the HOPE Center.
And Dr. Green has also earned
lots of different accolades
over the years, I did want
to mention one in particular,
in 2019, Dr. Green received
the National Association
of Social Workers,
New York City's Chapter's
Social Work I.M.P.A.C.T. Award.
And this award is presented
to a social worker
who exemplifies a commitment
to social justice, equity,
empowerment and civil rights
through their work, research,
advocacy, practice,
embodiment of the social work profession
and also their dedication
to communities and individuals they serve.
So again, someone who's been
deeply invested in this work
over the years and we're grateful
to be able to have Dr. Green
join us on the podcast today.
Thanks for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
- And our third guest
is Dr. Warren Kinghorn,
Dr. Kinghorn is a psychiatrist who teaches
at the Duke University Medical School,
he also is a co-director
of the Theology, Medicine
and Cultural Initiative
at Duke Divinity School,
which offers opportunities to
students in health professions
and to pressing clinicians
who are studying for seminary as well.
So he's written on a lot of
different topics over the years,
including "The Philosophy
of Psychiatric Diagnoses",
"The Moral Dimensions of Combat Trauma"
and "The Role of
Clinician-Patient Relationships",
specifically as that relates
to medication prescribing.
He's also written about the
way that Christian communities
understand mental health
and mental illness.
So a lot of what's relevant
to this conversation today
and grateful to have Dr.
Kinghorn here with us, welcome.
- Thank you Dr. Addy,
really pleased to be here.
- Well again, I think it's
gonna be a great conversation,
we have all these different perspectives
that we bring to the table
but as I often do on these podcasts,
I just want to start out just
checking in with everybody
and seeing how you're doing
in the midst of everything
that's happened the last few weeks,
over the last year and a
half and even beyond that.
So Pastor Mike, if we could
go ahead and start with you.
- Yeah, no, I am well.
I mean, the past 18 months,
I think for all of us
has been challenging in different ways,
for those of us who are in church,
many have had to
re-imagine how we do church
and how we serve the
needs of the community
and the people who are
part of the congregation
and I've been blessed
because we're at a place
where I feel like we were
already a little ahead
of the game already, so much
of what we did was digital
and our virtual ministry and
programming was already up,
we just had to increase content,
so I'm grateful for the amazing team
and staff we have at FCBC.
On a personal level,
I mean, my wife and I are both
vaccinated, fully vaccinated
and we also both had COVID
and we did not have easy
bouts with it either.
It was extremely challenging
and I was one of the early,
we were some of the
earlier people who had it
when people didn't know
what it was in January,
we were just extremely sick
and she couldn't breathe
and I had the cough, I had
pneumonia in both lungs
and it was after everything
kinda got chaotic
in New York City, that we went
back and got an antibody test
and found that we had, we were
positive for the antibodies.
So we knew that when we were
sick, that's what it was
'cause it was worse,
it started out feeling like the flu
but it was 10 times worse
and it was really, but
I'm grateful, we had it,
my son had it, who lives up here as well
but we came through it
and as a congregation we're doing well
and personally we're doing
well, so I'm grateful.
- I'm glad to hear that,
I appreciate you sharing
so honestly about that path.
I mean, amidst the challenges
and even going through COVID
and not knowing that that's what it was
I can only imagine all
that came with that.
- Absolutely.
- Thanks so much
for sharing so potently.
And I imagine that's
also a source of strength
to have that testimony about
what you've gone through
as well as....
- Absolutely.
- At the same time.
- Absolutely, absolutely
and especially those,
like you said, those
who've gone through it
and also those who are still fearful
and that's why we really push vaccination,
we were a vaccination site
and will be again in the Fall
but it's important in our community.
- Yeah, that's so
important and so well said.
What about you Dr. Green, how
was this last year and a half
and even these last
few weeks been for you?
- Oh, well, it's been
a bit of a mixed bag,
I'm grateful to be on
the other side of it,
so with regard to work,
just super excited about
the opportunity that I have
to work at the HOPE Center,
I actually started here
during the pandemic,
so I started in September of 2020
when I received the
invitation from my pastor
to take on this new role
and excited that he did so
and grateful that it's thriving,
we're pretty much offering,
which I know we'll have a
chance to talk about later
but offering an array of
programs to the community,
so I'm grateful for
that, on a personal note,
I've definitely had
some personal challenges
during the pandemic, I too
have lost two family members
to COVID unfortunately
and then had some other medical issues
that I had to face during COVID,
so, went in for a surgery
and found out that I was
allergic to anesthesia
and ended up in the ICU
and since then I've actually
been seeing a herbalist
who has really helped me
to sort of stay healthy
in addition to just exercising
and doing the best around my mental health
but making sure that I'm
fueling my body with good stuff
and just looking at my health
from a holistic standpoint.
So I'm grateful for where I am right now.
- Wow, well, thanks for
sharing so honestly as well
and I think it's great,
I mean, you're in a way living by example
and talking about it, really
taking that holistic approach
and making sure that your health
is good all the way around
even despite those challenges.
So it seems in some ways you're,
and again, also on the other
side just going through.
- Yeah, and I tell
everybody who will listen.
- Excellent, excellent.
Dr. Kinghorn, what about you?
- Yeah, I am doing okay, I've
been fortunate to have a job
this whole time and patients
to see and students to teach
and reasonably good health
and my family's doing okay
but I have to say I'm
just tired right now,
both at the end of a semester
but also in the midst of just everything
that's been going on and I've
just been increasingly aware
in the last year really,
how just heavy everything around this is,
whether it's a patient of mine
who like Dr. Green has lost
two immediate family members
to COVID, to veterans that I care for
at the VA Hospital here in
Durham, who were really upset
at what happened on January the sixth
and like really kind
of had the world rocked
and seeing that too, I taught
a class on theology and trauma
here at Duke this Spring
and we tried to continue just to be aware
of what was happening in our
world and had even this Spring,
the shootings in Atlanta and
the repeated ongoing killings
of people of color,
whether it's Daunte Wright
and more recently, Andrew
Brown here in North Carolina
and seeing the way that my
students are bearing the weight
of that and feeling that
and on top of having an ongoing pandemic,
it just feels like a
really challenging season.
So I'm both grateful and also just aware
of how much is going on all around us.
- Yeah, that makes a lot
of sense in a lot of ways
and definitely appreciate your
awareness of that as well.
I mean, you're leading off talking
about, I imagine you do this
with your students as well
but your own tiredness,
so not to ignore that but to acknowledge
and I think all of us have
done that and acknowledged,
I mean, clearly some
having gone through COVID
as Pastor Mike mentioned
and Dr. Green also mentioned
some of the health challenges,
just the reality of what
we're all dealing with
and I think that goes a long way.
I imagine that will come
from the conversation as well
but I feel like that's
often a starting point,
just acknowledging the challenges
and then Dr. Kinghorn as you
mentioned, also acknowledging
the challenges your
students are going through
and empathizing, even if you can't relate
to every single component of it
but just being there as that voice
and that empathetic support
to really say, "Okay,
these are challenging times
and this is not something
that we can just ignore
and plow through".
I mean, I think in a lot of ways
that ties into this conversation,
the "Intersection of
Mental Health and Faith",
I mean, I'll pass it on to
Pastor Mike and Dr. Green
to elaborate on but I would
say even in my own experiences
in academic settings in the community,
oftentimes there isn't
that acknowledgement
at the first pass, so I've
talked to students who've said,
"oh, my aunt is struggling with depression
and she's being told
the only reason she's not getting better,
is because she isn't praying hard enough".
So yes, we're acknowledging
the power of God
but not acknowledging all the
tools we have at our disposal
to address those things
but then at the same time
I'll be teaching students
who will get very excited
about the biology of the brain
and how that impacts mental health
but say things like, "What
are we supposed to do
with those people that think
a higher power can help them
with their mental health challenges
or being a part of a faith community?"
So again, now being totally dismissive
about the other side of things
and I think oftentimes there's
not enough conversation
about how we need to look at
those things holistically.
And so that's one of the
reasons I'm so excited
about this conversation and the work
that you all have been involved
in, either on the ground
or as admirers and advocates of the work
and so, Pastor Mike and Dr. Green,
I just wanted to hear a
little bit about the journey
into that space of even
creating that HOPE Center.
I mean, this is the first
faith-based mental health center
in Harlem, it's unique in a lot of ways
and I'm curious how all that
came about in the first place.
- Well, I'll talk about that piece
and when we get to the exciting
work of the HOPE Center,
I'll let Dr. Green jump on it.
The journey really started,
towards the HOPE Center,
as personal.
I suffer with a rare disease
it's called CVID, Common
Variable Immunodeficiency
and basically, I was
born with no antibodies,
with a very low life expectancy
but what it has meant over the years,
is numerous infections,
numerous hospitalizations,
surgeries, you name it, near
death experiences, sepsis,
I've survived sepsis three times,
two of the three times,
(mumbles) was MRSA,
which is the worst bacteria to get.
I mean, so over the years what it caused
is a lot of depression.
When you're battling with chronic
illness, chronic sickness,
chronic pain, it has an impact
and I was dealing with all this
while pastoring in many ways
and it got to be a lot
and I found myself in and
out of depressive moments.
And I never at that time,
this is going back into
the early 2000s and beyond,
never sought out a therapist,
I think not that I was against therapy,
I just never thought to
look for a therapist.
I figured, I can handle it, I'm a pastor,
I preach every week, I teach,
I lead people through these
moments, I can come out of it
and then
in 2010
or seven rather, I was on a
trip to Seattle Washington
and I was staying in a hotel
on the 22nd floor of the hotel
and nothing, there was
nothing going on that day
that seemed strange or different
and I remember going out on the balcony
and I literally heard a
voice tell me, say to me,
"If you jump, you can survive".
That's what I heard.
It was the first time
I heard anything close
to suicidal ideation ever.
The voice just said, "If
you jump, you can survive"
and I remember kind of
feeling another presence
kinda pull me back into
this room off the balcony
and I remember laying in this bed
almost in a fetal position, just crying.
I didn't know what just happened
but it was very overwhelming
because in my entire life,
I never thought of that idea.
I had never conceived of
it, never entered my mind
about the notion of taking my own life
and I was able to understand
that's what was just happening
and it was literally a voice
as clear as you and I
are talking now Dr. Nii,
I heard it that, "If you
jump, you can survive".
And so that was kind of the first alarm
that something is not well
and again, still pushing through it,
still fighting through it,
still not seeing a therapist,
while at the same time
people are coming to me
for pastoral care and counseling,
while at the same time, in 2012,
Dr. Kinghorn, I was in Durham to preach
and got sick on a Wednesday,
at Duke Medical Center by Friday
and spent 14 days at Duke
Medical Center with sepsis
and I had MRSA and they had
no idea whether I'd survive.
- Wow.
- And when I came out of that in 2012,
I remember when I got better,
someone wanted to see me
about some issues they were
dealing with personally
and over the years, we as the
pastors had always gotten,
had sessions with people
whose issues were beyond
our ability to handle,
we found ourselves always referring
to spaces where they can
get mad mental health care
and I said to myself, one,
I need to find a therapist
and then I said, there are people
who are coming to the church
who are in need of care
beyond what we're capable of giving.
So when I started my journey in therapy,
is when we looked to hire a
part-time therapist on staff
to deal with some of the issues
that were beyond our scope as pastors.
All of us were trained,
all of us had pastoral care
and counseling, clinical
pastoral education
but there was still things
we just could not deal with,
so we hired her, her name was
at the time, Joyce Johnson
and it was pretty soon she got swamped.
She was there and then she
got overloaded with things
but one day when I was at
the church in the lobby
because when you come
to the information desk,
in the entrance,
the receptionist is like,
"Who are you here to see?"
Joyce had an office upstairs in the church
and I'm sitting in the lobby,
the person didn't know who I was,
they were not a member of the
church and when they came in
and when the receptionist asked the person
who were they coming to see,
they whispered Joyce's name.
I perceived in that moment,
there was still some shame,
like I'm coming here to see
someone about some issues
and the stigma, well, I'm
not crazy and nothing's wrong
but I noticed them whispering.
And I realized at that
moment, and this was in 2000,
towards maybe the beginning of 2013,
I said, having this space is not enough,
I wanna have a freestanding space
so people felt comfortable going in
because if you come to church
and you go to see Joyce,
people will think you're crazy.
That's what I was feeling
and so I had been looking,
so we have the Dream Center
that you talked about,
which is really cutting edge,
we do a lot of programming
but we got the space
because of a relationship
with one of our trustees
who is also a developer
and when he asked about
getting some community support
for this project he had,
I said, "Well, look, we're
going to give you support
but I got an idea, that
first floor of your building,
let us get that building.
We'll pay rent and we used
it for the Dream Center".
Well, in 2014, he needed
support for another space
around the corner from the church,
I said, "Listen, let's do the same thing.
Let's get this space", in that
moment it was like instant,
"let's use this space for
a mental health facility"
and that's where it started.
And for about a year and a
half, they worked on the space,
we were able to build it out
and then we had the ribbon
cutting in December of 2014,
16 rather for the HOPE
Center and we named it HOPE,
we had Dream and now we had HOPE,
Healing On Purpose and Evolving
where we offered
initially, we've changed it
but initially people who
came into the HOPE Center
and went through the process,
we didn't call them clients,
we called them HOPE Innovators.
We wanted to change the language,
persons who are creatively
finding paths towards healing
and wholeness, just changing the language,
changing the culture, changing the dynamic
but initially when you came
and you went through the
program and the application,
you got 12 free therapeutic
sessions, plus followup,
plus potentially involved
in group sessions as well.
So it was something that
I had never been done,
I mean, when you think about
the cost of 12 sessions
of therapy and we were offering
this for free initially,
we had some people who, we had a staff
but then we had two
volunteers, two women who...
it was amazing, they
had visited the church
and they weren't Christian,
they were actually Jewish
but they had been visiting
the church quite a bit,
they really liked the church
and they were psychiatrists
and so they offered their services.
- Wow.
- But like that first
year or so, year or two,
one got ill with cancer
but they were offering their services free
and because of their
presence, they would offer
to prescribe medication if necessary.
So we had our staff, our clinician,
plus we had these two psychiatrists
volunteering their services every weekend,
so it was amazing how things unfolded
and persons started making
donations and we were...
I mean, it was just great.
And 'cause I was of the belief
that if we build this space,
people will come and it was
to meet a particular need
because you know the stigma
in the Black community
that exists around mental
health and mental health issues
and so we wanted to engage
in de-stigmatizing that
and then I from the
pulpit, began preaching
about my personal battles
with depression and anxiety
and that opened up
what I thought if the
pastor can be transparent,
if I can talk about it,
it'll free other people up
to feel, hey, it's okay to talk about it
and it's okay to acknowledge it
and by the way, then we have a space
that can help you navigate this.
So yeah, I'll stop there for now.
- Wow, that's so powerful,
that's amazing to hear that story
just from your personal journey
and everything that came out
in the community as well.
I think it's so important that
you are acknowledging that
from the pulpit as well
'cause I think that helps
people in those moments
to know it's not a quick fix.
So I'm sure that's some of
what comes into it as well.
I mean, when I shared about that student,
basically, it's the mindset
that it hasn't been fixed yet
because you're not putting in
enough effort in your prayer
for God to address that
but you mentioned that from the pulpit
and so people know the journey
and I think that's so important.
- Yeah, and I had those
same comments before this
and I had a woman say to me one time,
a member of the church,
she said, "Well, pastor,
I understand what you're
doing but I got to trust God
and I believe demons",
and she went through this whole thing.
And I asked her,
I said, "Do you have
any physical ailments?"
And she told me, "Yes", she
said, "I have diabetes".
I said, "So is God dealing with that
or you got medication?"
And she said, "Well,
I take insulin shots".
I said, "Oh", I said, "Okay,
so you trust the doctors
with the diabetes but you
don't trust practitioners
with mental health issues?"
and she just paused
and she just paused and
that was the reality.
There's no stigma
around going to the
hospital when you're sick
and we often talk about that.
You break your arm,
nobody's saying, "Oh my God,
you going to go to the
hospital to get that fixed?"
No, but there's a stigma around
issues around the spirit,
around the mind, around it soul
and we have to do that work
of really, like I said, de-mythologizing
and de-stigmatizing those issues
and I think the more we do it
and the more we've been talking about it,
we've seen a change in
the language of people
in the community.
And also having a space, it's
one thing to talk about it
from the pulpit and to make
it a priority to the church,
it's another thing to have a space
that you can say, "By the
way, here's the therefore,
here's the therefore,
therefore there's this space".
- Yeah, that's so important,
I'm so honored to be, just
hearing about the work
that you've been doing on the ground
and the sense to really set this up.
I was gonna pivot to Dr.
Green and hear a little bit
about some of that as well and
even just, one of the points
that Pastor Mike, that you brought up
as I was listening to it,
it seemed like that tension was ongoing.
You talked about the
first person who came in
who was volunteering, who was overwhelmed,
so obviously there's a need..
- Well, she wasn't volunteering,
she was being paid...
- She was getting paid...
- We were paying her,
she worked part-time.
We wanted to make sure
we got good services.
- So even as she's doing
that, being overwhelmed
but then people are still
whispering about going to see her.
So it seems like both of
those were kinda happening
at the same time.
So Dr. Green, like how
has that moved forward
on the ground level as a director?
How do you see that play out?
Do you feel like you're dealing
with both simultaneously
or people are getting better
at acknowledging the need
or are you still trying to
break through the stigma?
What's that whole process
like at this point?
- Yes, I would say it's
a little bit of both.
And so for me,
my mantra has always been you can pray
and go to therapy.
So I'm also very active in the community
and always have been and
so people have always known
that I'm a mental health
clinician, I'm a psychotherapist
and so having those
conversations with people
has always been something
that's been super easy for me.
And so pastor brought up the
example of talking to the woman
about her medical condition and
would she go to the hospital
to seek treatment for that?
And that's a great place to start
because I think it's
helping people to unpack
their thought process around
mental health treatment
and there are all these things
that sort of go in there.
But part of it also too, is
this, I think this conspiracy
of silence around the
mental health challenges
that people have experienced
for many, many years
and haven't really had an
opportunity to talk about it,
we can talk about the
issues around discrimination
and racism that have also
plagued the mental health system
that has sort of impacted people's ability
to trust the systems of
care that are in place,
feeling like they can also
seek treatment and places
and with people who also look like them.
So all of those things
sort of go into that.
And so I think we do a good job
at keeping the conversation
open and transparent and clear
and also not taking
ourselves too seriously.
Like just saying, "Hey,
we have this thing here,
it's free and it's available"
and I'll say things to folks
like, "Where can you go
and get some things for free?
How often can you go and do that?"
And they're like, "Well, no..."
and then I may say to them,
"What are some of the things
that are important to you?"
When I'm talking to
some of the millennials
who wanna have a conversation
around the cost of mental health
and I say, "Well, how often do you shop?
How much did you pay for
the last pair of shoes?
And the same ways in
which you go for brunch
or you go shopping, it's
building space into your life
and making spaces in your life
for things that are important to you,
so how do you prioritize that?
And then if your mental
health is not a priority,
well, now let's talk about that too".
So there are always these
ongoing conversations
around how to open up the door
just to have the conversation
and to make it welcoming.
And so we've done our
best to do that here,
so we offer the sessions
but one of the things that
have been important to me,
is making sure that we have a
ton of public-facing programs
as well.
And so we have right now implemented
what we call "our healing
conversations" on a monthly basis
and we tackle really tough
issues at least once a month
and so we've tackled suicide,
we've tackled domestic violence,
we've tackled grief and
loss, actually last month,
this month we're gonna
be talking about anxiety
and then in June,
which will be our last
healing conversation,
we're gonna be talking about
the importance of sleep
and rest and what does that
mean in our daily lives?
I've also been able to develop
some fantastic partnerships
with a bunch of organizations
in the community,
we don't see children here,
the folks that we see here
are 18 and over, so it's
been important for us
to cultivate relationships with
places that provide services
to adolescents and children and
so we've been in the process
of tying to develop that as well
but one point with regard to the need,
is that when I came
here to the HOPE Center,
we had a waiting list of 76 people.
- Wow!
- And some of those folks
had been on the waiting list
for over a year.
And so one of my first priorities
was to sort of look at that
list, go back to those folks
and prioritize like who's sort of
in high need of care
services, who was in crisis.
And then we were also still
in the middle of COVID,
so how could we then provide
programming that folks,
people who were also suffering from loss
and so we've been in the
process of doing that.
So two relationships that we've built
that I've been so proud to
participate in is our partnership
with Columbia University
Center for Complicated Grief,
so all of my staff here,
including the interns
have trained in
complicated grief services,
they also get rigorous suicide training
and mental health counseling
training of course,
I'm a field instructor as well,
as well as a professor at NYU
and I'm an adjunct faculty
there, so I get to make sure
that I'm being consistent
with the kinds of training
and teaching that students need here
to be successful clinicians
out in the community.
We also make sure that we pay
attention to issues of race,
issues of power and
privilege, all of those things
and making sure that the staff
here is also quite diverse.
And so we do all of that, we make sure
that we are paying attention
to our own mental health needs,
so when Pastor Mike was
talking, one of the things
that has always been taught
to me by my own mentors
is that the healers need healing
and the healers need spaces to go as well.
And so making supervision
part of, and therapy,
a consistent part of your life.
And so that's why this year,
we came up with our tagline
for our theme this year, which
is "Healing is a Lifestyle"
to really cultivate and encourage folks
to continue on that path for wellness
and that journey to wellness.
- That's so great,
I mean, that's such a
holistic approach too
and you're tackling so
many things at once,
which are so critical.
I mean, even dealing with
the stigma on the front end,
making sure that you're covering
all the different topics
that influence mental
health including sleep,
making sure that you're
talking about the impact
of the racial injustices and racism
and then partnering with those outside,
so I think in so many ways,
this model that you all have
developed is so important
and so effective.
And so Dr. Kinghorn, I'm actually curious,
as someone who's been an
admirer and an advocate
of this work, what are some of the things
that have stood out to you
about just the importance of
the work that they're doing
in Harlem and what has caught your eye
as someone who has your
foot in both worlds,
both in faith community
and as a psychiatrist?
- Thank you, yeah, I've
been a distant admirer
of the HOPE Center for quite a while,
I first learned about HOPE Center
through the work of my
colleague and psychiatrist,
Sidney Hankerson at Columbia University,
who is doing really unique research,
a federally-funded research on
the role of faith communities
and especially of churches
in depression intervention
and I've learned a lot
from Dr. Hankerson's work.
One of his early published
papers, which he published
in the Journal of Urban
Health was a focus group study
with pastors at a church
in New York and Queens,
so it wasn't First Corinthians Baptist
but I interviewed a lot of of pastors
around their experience
in a predominantly
African-American large church
in New York City around how
they encountered depression
and these pastors recognized
that depression was present
in their community,
they wanted the church
to be a site of support
and they also really
helpfully though said,
"We have to think about depression
not just as like an
individual medical problem
that needs treatment but
we need to also situate it
in the context of the lived
realities of people's lives;
of jobs stress, of
financial stress, of racism,
of problems with education
and accessing medical care",
and it pointed to the
way in which churches
can actually be sites of outreach
and support and connection
even more but partnering
with medical systems
but how can churches be, do
that kind of connecting work
and especially not just recognizing
the way in which mental
health problems don't exist
in a vacuum, they take
place in a kind of community
and culture and sets of relationships.
And so when I hear about the HOPE Center
being situated within a church,
made possible by a church,
providing pathways to high
quality mental health care
and also they're responding to the needs
of the local community,
which in some ways is the
needs of our entire country,
I'm just really excited about it
and just really have been
so excited to see it grow
over the years and to hear about its work
and to hear more about
it through my connections
at Duke Divinity School with Pastor Mike.
- Yeah, that's so well said
and it's so encouraging to hear
about the work that's being
done on multiple fronts
and some of these connections as well.
I know Dr. Hankerson has
been very well connected
to this initiative
and I think there's so much
that others can learn as well.
And so I'm actually curious to know,
as you all have been moving through this
and kinda breaking down
some of these barriers
and empowering people,
are there aspects that you
think can be expanded and used
and applied in other places as well
or is this something that's
unique to the environment
that you have in Harlem
and the relationships there
or are there principles that you see
that could actually be
replicated by others
in other parts of the country?
- Well, a few things,
one,
well, two things actually,
one, I've had conversations
with other colleagues in
ministry, about the HOPE Center
and wanting to do this,
wanting to try to replicate it
in some way, shape or form
and the conversation at some
point turns into a conversation
about church budgets
and I'll tell you why,
because the first question is resources.
We used to be told, "Budgets
are moral documents"
and I would say, "No, budgets
are vision documents to me",
where do you see yourself,
where do you wanna go
as a church, and the reason
why I brought this up
is because when we opened the HOPE Center
for the first few years,
there was no public money,
it was all church donations
that funded it, that staffed it,
that kept it going.
And what we made a priority
for the church initially,
is that this was important,
this was meeting a need
in the community and we put
our resources where the need is
and this was a great need.
And so the people believed in
it, the church believed in it,
the leadership believed in it
and were able to give to it
to make sure that it was able to function
and sustain itself.
That's the first thing.
I think a lot of times in ministry,
we do ministry based on
ideas, not always need
and so I had to tell a
lot of my colleagues that
and it became important.
Secondly, myself and Dr.
Hankerson and others have talked
about using the HOPE
Centers, I just kind of spoke
in real model, it can be replicated.
I think if more faith-based institutions
had this kind of presence
in the community,
it could go a long way
again, in de-stigmatizing
the narrative and what you find
is that many faith-based
institutions want to do it
but they begin talking about resources.
So I think there are institutions
that have the capacity to do it
but I think there are tons
of resources out there
for people to begin these initiatives
but I do think there's a
willingness by many clergy.
So that's one of my dreams,
to see HOPE Center is in other places.
I've talked with Dr. Green about this,
that how do we make this happen
in other parts of the city for now
and then make it something
that transcends the city
because it serves a great need,
listen, here's the reality,
we're doing a great work,
Dr. Green and her team
are doing a great work
but we we're still, in
some ways overwhelmed
and we've run out of space.
So it was like, when we
opened it from within,
I would say within the first nine months
we realized we were already
tapped off of space.
- Wow!
- So we, Dr. Green has
talked to me about that,
about needing a bigger
space, which is a good thing,
so that we can offer more services
and have a more adequate space,
conducive for the kind of
clinical work that's being done,
so I'm just,
I'm grateful for these challenges we have
but I'm also grateful
for the possibilities
and I'm grateful for Dr. Green
because I think she not
only has the ability
but the vision to make the
larger vision come to pass
for the HOPE Center.
- I just wanna add too about,
with regard to resources
and I wasn't there in the beginning,
I've been connected to First
Corinthians Baptist Church
since 2006 and working in
ministry under Pastor Mike
for quite a while before
I came to the HOPE Center.
But one of the things that I will say
is that just beginning the conversations
around mental health and
seeing what resources
are within your own congregation
because I think you would be surprised
about
what may come up.
Pastor Mike talked about
these two psychiatrists
who decided that they
wanted to donate their time.
So I think just beginning there
and having the conversation
and being open about the
kinds of things that you need
and the kinds of things
that you'd like to see,
I wanted to mention also
too, that with Dr. Hankerson,
one of the things that we did at FCBC
was do this mental health
first aid training.
And that started with Dr.
Hankerson training our pastors
and our deacons initially,
and then opening that up
to other volunteers who were interested
in just having a basic understanding
to have a one-on-one on
mental health first aid
and sort of how to intervene in a crisis.
And so you don't necessarily
always have to have experts
on hand, that's a great
place for you to start
and then that sort of
develops into other things
and so one of the things
that we're doing now
in partnership with Dr. Hankerson,
is in June, we're gonna
be embarking on a study
that focuses on understanding
the experiences of depression
in Black men.
And so we're really looking
forward to that because we know
that offer some additional
really good information
about how to provide
resources and services
and engage men overall.
So I think just again,
starting the conversation,
seeing what resources you have within
and just starting, making the
commitment to start somewhere.
- I think it's so great
that you both really pulled that out...
- And I wanna add to that,
if you think about, I
remember when, this was before
the HOPE Center was really an
idea, we had Joyce Johnson,
Ms. Johnson and Dr. Hanks and I
would have numerous conversations,
so when we did the mental
health first responders
kind of training, we had almost 300 people
that ended up being trained.
- Wow!
- And it was amazing because we realized,
not only was there a need
but it was an interest
from the community to help
and to be a part of this.
And it was amazing over
a period of some months
these trainings took place
but the amount of people who came out,
I was surprised by the
numbers 'cause I didn't know
it would be that many people
but many people wanted to be part of this,
part of these kinds of healing efforts,
so I just had to know that
because it was really impressive
when we first started that
with Dr. Hankerson.
- Yeah, that's great,
that was actually gonna
be my next question
'cause I was curious just what
the reception had been like
as we talked about just
people having a hesitancy,
whether people were open
to that first aid training,
mental health first aid training,
did they feel like they needed it
but I mean, just those
numbers that you mentioned,
it seems like both the need and
the desire were really there
which I think is outstanding.
Dr. Kinghorn, I'll be
curious to hear your thoughts
on some of this as well,
some of these topics
that we're talking about
within the Harlem community,
and what you've seen in
other parts of the country
or even nationally in terms
of, one, is there an openness
to these conversations or
are people still resistant,
either in the faith community
or in the medical community
to really have these
integrated conversations?
- Yeah, it's a great question.
I think the HOPE Center is
such a great model of success
even though I know
there's ongoing challenges
around growth and sustainability,
in my, there are examples in
other parts of the country
of mental health centers and
efforts that are church-led,
in my experience, they
tend to be successful
when three things are present.
One, you got to have a
committed church leadership
that often leads from personal
experiences of church leaders
and it shouldn't be
housed in just one person,
like one pastor who's the champion
but it needs to be
something that's embraced
by the community, we gotta
have a specific leader
of the initiative that has the
right kind of clinical wisdom
and training and skills
and I think both of those
things are well represented
on our call today by
Pastor Mike and Dr. Green
and you also have to have a center
that understands its community
and the needs of its
community and is responding
to specifically what's
present in the community
and so these efforts
tend to look different
in different places, in different cities,
depending on what the needs are.
With respect to the broader questions,
I think, around how
conversations about mental health
are happening in churches
and I am interested in Pastor Mike's
and Dr. Green's perspective on this,
there's certainly a stereotype out there
that churches are not safe spaces
to talk about mental
health and mental illness
and that stereotype has
a grounding in reality,
it's still often the
case that that's true,
I think over the last
10 or 15 years actually,
I've noticed a lot more
willingness of people to talk
and the engagement of churches
and books being written
and being podcast and being published,
where Christians are talking
about their own experience
of mental illness, where
Christians are calling the church
to be more active and engaged
and so that's all really good
and that's happening
in a variety of different church contexts,
that's happened in a
variety of different ways,
including in Black church settings,
so Monica Coleman's book,
"Bipolar Faith" has been something
that a lot of my students
have found really helpful
in de-stigmatizing mental
illness in the Black community
and I think that all of
that is really important.
I think again, kinda going
back to Dr. Hankerson's work,
I think one of the challenge
is when the church does begin
to talk about mental health
problems, how not to make it
just a matter of individual
people having problems
but how do we both recognize
that mental illness
and mental health challenges
are deeply individual
and we can provide help to
individuals and to families
and also to locate them
in a broader social, cultural
context, like what's happening
in our, with our policies
and with our programs
and with the way our
communities are structured
and things like housing that
might give rise to that.
And I think that's where
some of the conversations
around church and mental
health need to expand some
to have a kind of broader
social perspective
so it's not just a matter of
individual treatment-seeking
although that's really important.
- Yeah, I think that's really well said
and it's helpful to hear
some of those parallels
and just to know what you're
equipping your students with
as well, and I think all
these pieces of conversation
are so, so powerful.
I'm curious for those who are listening,
from two sides who may be listening,
who may be a member of a faith community
or a member of a church and are listening
and saying that all of
these things sound great
and they sound like
they're great initiatives
and it's good to be
able to have the vision
and the plugin of resources
but those who feel isolated
and don't know where to start.
So people who may have
tried to approach questions
of mental health within the church
and feel like they're getting pushed back
and they don't know where to go to,
do any of you have advice
for someone in that situation
about how to move forward
and then at the same
time, what if that person
is actually a leader?
So someone who's in a leadership position
but feels like the leadership
is not in line with them,
where do those individuals
and how do they really plug in
to really get to a better place?
- I think, here's the reality,
there are a lot of churches
and we've all alluded to this earlier,
where we have over-spiritualized
what we know to be mental health issues
and because of that, and because
many churches still operate
within certain theological traditions
and certain theological frameworks,
that tragically don't make
room for the possibility
that there is something here
at work beyond the demonic.
It is amazing how today in
2021, that with all the data,
with all the research, with
all the work that is being done
around mental health issues,
that there are still people
who approach this with a
primitive frame of mind
and who do not acknowledge
that there are issues at stake
that are not, that are
beyond the narrative
of demon possession or
we need to pray this away
or we need to pray, fast and
tarry and all these things.
So I think for people who
are in those kinds of spaces,
one, I don't think that they
ought to discount the reality
that they live or know
because what happens is that
when you enter certain spaces
that do not acknowledge these realities,
there is a sense of dismissiveness
that can be destructive
and even disastrous for people,
not just who wanna talk
about it or not just people
who are living in these spaces
because what churches
have to also acknowledge
is that we have participated
in those who have been silenced
and remain silent in their suffering
because of sometimes the lack of empathy
and even the punitive
language that emerges
from some of our faith institutions.
So what I would tell someone
is, do not let the behavior
of a particular institution
become definitive
for the possibilities of what can happen
and like, as Dr. Kinghorn
said, you have to find a space
and a place that values
that, that affirms this
that not only that affirms the reality
of mental health issues
but also is doing what Dr.
Green alluded to earlier,
you can pray and get therapy,
you can be a deep believer
in God and seek treatment
and I'm a witness to that.
And I also think that
one of the other things
that have to happen
is, we've, I've gone, I've
been on panels, I've had talks
but I think there needs
to be gatherings as well
and we're doing something like that,
Dr. Green is helping in
doing something like this
in the fall
but gathering of clergy, being
able to pull clergy together,
whether it is in even in seminary
and I don't, I'm a proud
graduate of Duke Divinity School
but I don't know if
Warren Kinghorn was there
when we had this conversation,
you have many divinity schools
that no longer make a requirement,
pastoral care and counseling to graduate
with a degree in divinity,
which is amazing because
now we have persons
who are leading institutions
who may not have had even
a modicum of understanding
of issues around mental
health and mental wellness.
So, I mean, those are some ways
but getting clergy together
to begin to hear narratives
because what you will discover,
clergy too suffer in silence
because of the expectation
that people have of clergy
to be the problem-solvers, the healers
but as Dr. Green alluded
to, there comes a time
when the healers need healing
to deal with their own psychic fractures
and I agree to it anecdotally,
what really triggered me in
a major way to really commit
to this initiative of the HOPE
Center was a friend of mine,
a good friend of mine that
I went to college with
had another friend that
I knew marginally though
but I knew of him.
And on a Sunday morning, he
had two services at his church,
an eight o'clock and an 11 o'clock service
and on this particular
Sunday, his family, his wife
and children, two children
were at home getting ready
and they missed the first service
and were coming to the 11 o'clock service.
So he goes to church, he
preached the eight o'clock sermon
for the service.
He went home between services,
they didn't live far from the church
and his wife and kids were
getting ready, were ready
and he said, "You all go ahead,
I'll meet you at the church
I have to do a couple of things".
And so the wife and the
children left to go to church,
he's getting ready to
preach the 11 o'clock sermon
and left the house, went in
his car, went in the driveway,
took out a gun and shot
himself in the head.
So after preaching the
eight o'clock service,
he committed suicide.
And what was amazing is, is
that talking to my friend,
that at the funeral, no
one mentioned suicide,
no one mentioned
that there was some kind
of depression going on
'cause he had been battling
depression for some time
and hadn't really, only
shared it with a few friends.
There was as if he just
died of natural causes
and no conversation during,
or no con after or before
about what this man had
been suffering with.
That is because the
family was still hesitant,
I imagine of the stigma
connected that a pastor
'cause the idea is if you trust
God, if you believe in God,
why, and you lean into God in prayer,
why would you need to commit suicide?
And so the people surrounding him
still bought into that narrative
and were almost ashamed
to speak about the fact that
this pastor committed suicide.
If you look at some of the
numbers, I know Dr. Kinghorn,
I mean, some years ago, I
think Duke had done a study
about the number of clergy
who were actually committing suicide
and the clergy, amount
of clergy studies show
about who, are suffering depression.
And I mean, it is amazing
but again, if there's any group
of people who are suffering
in silence, it is pastors who
have these great expectations
to keep them, pawn them from congregations
that they're almost invincible
and nothing can penetrate
the strength that they have
been endowed with by God
and so they suffer in silence.
- Yeah, that's so
important, that so important
and I appreciate you bringing that out
and just, I mean, so
much that needs to be...
is that something that you all
have tried to tackle head-on
in the work in the HOPE Center?
I mean, what do you feel like is different
about what you're doing there?
- I would say directly
in terms of clergy, no
but I think what we've been
doing in the HOPE Center,
I like what Dr. Green
and I wonder if she'll talk more about it
but there's clinical work
but I think where a lot of
the traction has taken place
with regard to change in the narrative,
is a lot of the public-facing
work she talked about.
I think that is to me,
there's no, that's where
a lot of the weight
of the potential we have
for impact really goes
and I would love to
her expand on that more
because of what that means.
When we have these programs,
these wellness check-ins
and the like, and I let
her talk more about that,
I think it goes a long way in
terms of the public realizing
that this institution is
about more than just saying,
"Hey, if you have something
going on mentally,
come over to us".
No it's about life and
wellness and wellbeing.
- Yeah, so on that note, Dr. Green,
how are people responding to
the public-facing component?
- Our response I think,
has been really great,
I would say at the
beginning of the pandemic,
the HOPE Center engaged
into virtual opportunity
that both happened on Facebook.
So we started doing mindfulness moments,
so 30 minutes of
mindfulness-based practices,
so anything from breath
work, to yoga, to meditation,
so that happens every Tuesday
and then every Thursday, we
have our wellness check-ins
again, those are virtually as well
and people are able to just pop on
and just sort of get a
word, an encouraging word
for 15 to 20 minutes from someone
and we have an array of
people that participate,
so they're either pastors,
they might be a motivational
speaker, they are our interns,
our clinical interns here, I've
done a couple when I have to
but we invite folks
who have just sort of
like upbeat personality
and then also clinicians to join us
to do those virtual moments twice a week
and those have been great.
We've also partnered
with an organization called MYX Fitness,
so they've been joining us
because they are a group of
wellness and fitness instructors
who come on once a month
and participate in our
virtual mindfulness moments
and share something with us.
So whether it's fitness,
whether it's stretching,
whether it's tapping
meditation for anxiety,
so it's been great,
we've gotten a lot of
positive feedback on that
and also to those
sessions live on Facebook
and so people can share them
or where they can watch them
as often as they'd like.
So those have been fantastic for us
and so
we're trying to think
about how do we continue
to offer these things as we
move sort of out of the pandemic
and the world opens up a little bit more,
what does that look like now
that people have to go in?
The other things that we've been doing
that are public-facing
are just doing groups,
so we've had some fantastic
response to our group
so we did a group for new
and expectant parents,
an (murmurs) group that sort of focused
on an array of different issues
that are important to moms,
whether it's getting ready for
baby, postpartum depression,
understanding the ways
in which you can get care
including adding a
doula, which is important
because for particularly for
women of color, Black women
there's an issue around
maternal mortality rates
and we wanna figure out how
to support them around that
and as well as their
maternal mental health.
We provided a CBT-based
skills group as well
that actually had been the
most popular group to date
and again, all of our services are free,
from May, we're gonna be
doing wellness Wednesdays,
so that's gonna be a four-week series
and then in June, we have
something just for the guys
that's gonna be focused
on unmasking masculinity
and that's gonna be led
by our male therapist here
and we perhaps need get another topic.
So, and then we just finished
our HOPE Center weekend
where Pastor Mike
and our in-house male
clinician were able to focus
on a men's talk.
So we're figuring out ways
in which he can again,
bump up the public-facing opportunities
because we know that people
may not necessarily be ready
to start individual therapy
but in all of those opportunities,
we certainly make the pitch
for it, we provide resources,
so we have a number where
folks can text to get services,
we always provide our national
suicide hotline number
where folks can call and
then at any given point,
we provide resources to all
of the groups in the program
that we provide.
So we try to continue to keep
the conversation that way
and remind folks that services are here,
free here at the HOPE Center
and that they can call
and, or go online and sign
up to get an appointment
and it's free and confidential.
And so that is I think
the important messages
that we try to share consistently
so that folks know that
there's a resource available.
- Yeah, and again, that's
so across the board
in terms of topics and all those pieces,
I think that's wonderful.
How are people walking into that space?
I mean, is there, are people walking in
in kind of in a, they are creeping in
and don't wanna be seen, are
people open and enthusiastic,
is it a mixture of both?
Because I mean, when
you talked about that,
some of the conversations that you have,
trying to break that stigma
and there's so many rich
resources you're providing,
I'm just curious how people,
how they are entering in
in the first place.
- So everyone's virtually entering in.
- True.
- Our doors aren't open right now
although there's a number
of the staff who are here
during the week, so our
interns, our executive assistant
and myself are here during the week
but all of our services are virtual
and people can actually call,
so they can call and get a live person
and have to actually speak to someone
or they can go on and
sign up confidentially
and then I go ahead and
assign someone to a therapist,
assign a potential
innovator to a therapist
and then they go ahead and
get a phone call, an email,
so we do about three to
four outreach attempts
in an effort to get them
engaged into therapy
and then if not, they go
back onto the waiting list
as we continue to have a waiting list.
And even with myself, we
also have a psychologist,
we work with Dr. Hankerson,
who's a psychiatrist
and then we've had nine interns,
so even with nine interns
and the clinical staff,
we still had a significant waiting list.
So that's why we operate the groups too
so people have an
opportunity to get engaged.
- Well, that's great and in a lot of ways,
it seems like, I mean, in
some ways the virtual piece
may have helped to give
people that space to not...
I mean, not that the stigma
doesn't have to be dealt with
at some point but just to
really to be able to enter in
and I would imagine that
having the experience
may have also helped as
people are getting exposed
to all these resources, may
even help break down that stigma
and make other
opportunities going forward.
So, and as you hinted,
I guess that will be a challenge
coming back into the world
in a sense to see how that
dynamic will go forward.
- Yeah, I certainly think
that virtual programming is here to stay,
I don't think that we'll ever go back
to non-virtual services,
whether it's for medical appointments
or for mental health appointments,
I think we've all had some,
a major learning curve
during the pandemic around how
do we provide these services,
good quality services in a virtual space.
And so I would say prior to the pandemic,
I was probably a therapist
that was on the fence
about being in the room with someone
because of all the things that
you receive from one another
as you're working towards
your wellness journey.
But certainly been able to
do that in a virtual space
and I'm grateful for that opportunity,
so we've all been Zooming.
- Yeah, that makes sense in a lot of ways
and even thinking back
to those individuals
who may feel like they
don't have that support
in their own...
I mean, I don't know if
you've seen that at all
from people from other faith communities,
again, getting back to that
Pastor Michael mentioned,
who feel like they can step into this
and maybe a different
faith-based community
that has moved the conversation forward
and that has some of
those pieces available,
so I think those things are
options for people as well
so that can also provide
a lot of opportunity
that wasn't there in
the past in some ways.
- Yeah, absolutely and I've been able
to do some presentations
with some community of faith,
whether it's through the mayor's office
or the consortium through
one of the hospitals
and so folks I think are a
little bit open to having me come
and present and talk about the HOPE Center
and the services that we provide here
and while our, Pastor Mike
shared that at the HOPE Center
was originally created to provide services
to the congregation, we
don't turn anyone away.
So we have people who
are receiving services
who aren't members of our FCBC community
but they may be in Paris
or Germany or Ireland
and so we're, I'm
excited that we're global
and that folks can touch
base and get treatment
no matter where they are.
- Yeah, that sounds so powerful
and expansion in some ways as well.
And so, I mean, this is so,
this is such a rich conversation
and so many pieces to pull out
and again, I'm just grateful
for some of the practical contents
that you've talked about as well
and so I think for our listeners
a lot of those will go a long way,
specifically for those who feel isolated
in their specific situations.
But as we continue, or start to wrap up,
Dr. Kinghorn I was gonna ask
you, from your perspective
as someone, again, on both
sides, both a psychiatrist
and a theologian who's
working at Divinity School
and as someone who's admired
the work of the HOPE Center,
what do you, what is giving you hope
in the work that you're doing
yourself and in the work
that you're seeing Pastor
Mike and Dr. Green doing
in terms of how we're
moving things forward?
- It's a great question.
I think I am feeling, I think
it's important to hold hope
and challenge together
that you can only really
understand what hope is
when you are willing to see
the enormity of challenge.
And I think that both,
in terms of what we've
been describing today
and in terms of Christian faith, I think
that there is, we have a lot of resources.
So on one hand, I think that
the challenges are immense
and especially the challenges
in the pandemic are immense,
everything that's happening
in the world all around us
I also though think
that it's tempting in the
midst of big challenges
to hit despair, to think
like this is just the way
it's going to be, we
just have to hunker down,
we just have to push through
and I think our Christian faith teaches us
that we are loved by God before all else
and that humans are created with dignity
and in image of God and that...
and also that God is already
doing the work of healing
before us and around us
and that we don't generate this ourselves
through our own like energy and time
and, as if we're (murmurs)
but we're participating
in God's ongoing healing
work in the world.
And so as a psychiatrist
who's also a Christian,
I wanna say, how do I just
kind of join in that lane
to like join in the work
that the Holy Spirit is
already doing in the world
and that takes maybe some of
the felt pressure off of me
but it also puts pressure on me
to like continue to kind
of seek out that space
and that area.
And so I think, and I also
think that as a psychiatrist,
I can often get in the mode of fixing,
like patients presenting
me with a problem,
I got to fix them.
And I think that our faith gives us
a different kind of frame
that we are not machines
that need to be fixed but we
are those who are on a journey,
from God to God and that this
life is a kind of journey
through life to God
and we walk, we ourselves are on a journey
and anyone who we try to help
or to minister to or with
is also on a journey,
so we walk as Wayfair is
alongside others on a journey.
And so we can ask ourselves
like, what's needed right now
for the journey and that
makes it very practical
because what's needed
might be a medication
or what's needed might
be a course of ECT or TMS
be a 12-session course
of psychotherapy or what's
needed might be a men's group
or what's needed might be a meal
or to get out of an abusive relationship.
And so I think that being a
Christian gives me permission
to think broadly about
this kinds of things
and to, and hope that this
work didn't start with me or us
or any of us on this episode,
it doesn't end with us
but it's going on and we get a chance
to participate in that.
And that gives me hope and
then just to see witnesses
like Pastor Mike and Dr. Green and others
in other places doing
really creative work,
I look at that and I think,
man, this is so deeply needed
and to be able just to see
that unfold and to celebrate it
is something that I think
is just really profoundly encouraging.
- Wow, that's so well said
and I just love that approach
too and the framework
of really just looking
at things holistically
and bringing all aspects
and all tools to the table,
so I definitely appreciate
you sharing that
and I know you're being humble
and I know you're deeply
involved in that work
in so many ways as well,
so I deeply appreciate it for
the way that you're doing that
and the way that you're
impacting the next generation
of folks who will be doing
this both as clinicians,
as psychiatrists, as pastors and teachers,
so I also just want to acknowledge that
and make sure that that's acknowledged
and known to our audience as well.
- Thank you, Dr. Nii and all
of us I think are in that role
on this call, so I thank you.
- Dr. Green, what about you?
Even that juxtaposition goes
back to what you mentioned
at the beginning about even
your own personal challenges
in the midst of the hope
that you have as a Christian
and the hope that you're
providing in your work,
how do you continue to think
about that going forward?
- So, Dr. Kinghorn said
it so perfectly too,
I think about how do we do this work
and how are we called to do this work?
And we're always called to
do it in relationship, right?
And so that's what really is at the heart
of what we're trying to
do in therapy and groups
on this healing journey, is
that I'm walking alongside you
in this relationship
on this healing journey
and how can I support you
on this and how do I learn
because I tell folks all
the time when they come here
and they, Dr. Kinghorn
mentioned, we wanna fix
but also our clients or our
innovators expect us to fix it.
And so I also say to people,
"Well, you're the expert
on your own life.
I'm here to listen, I'm here
to maybe pick out some things
that maybe you didn't,
you weren't aware of
or to challenge you in
new and different ways
or expand your thinking ways
but you're the expert on that
and we're both learning
in this space together".
And so I think that that's
an important lens to have
in working with with people
who are on this journey
to healing and then also
just continually thinking
about how do I personally
intentionally cultivate spaces
of joy?
What does that look like for me on a daily
and consistent basis?
And I don't, sometimes I
don't do it every single day
but reminding myself to
be intentional about it,
reminding the people around
me to be intentional about it
and holding myself accountable.
- Yeah, that's so well said,
I love that relational piece
and holding ourselves accountable to joy.
I mean, I think that goes such a long way.
Pastor Mike, to wrap up,
there's so much that's been said here,
I guess not even just hope for yourself
but you should be able to
encourage our listeners too
in ways to continue to find hope
'cause I'm sure there are
those who are listening,
who are struggling and who
are trying to find a way out.
Any word you want to
speak to them directly?
- Yeah, there's a, many years
ago, a line I heard or I read
by late Howard Thurman, who has served
as one of my own spiritual
and theological mentors
along my journey as a
believer and as a pastor
and he was frequently saying
that the contradictions
of life are not final.
And I think in these past 18 months,
we've seen many harsh
realities that have sought
to, in some places, assault
life or undermine life
and have given birth to many realities
that many of us did not know
were even possibilities for us,
meaning depressive moments,
moments filled with anxiety
that this pandemic
brought to the forefront
but I think it's always a
good reminder to tell people
for me personally, that those
contradictions are not final,
they do not hold the final word,
they're not definitive on our lives,
that we have not only power through God
but transcendent power to overcome
and see our way through
these kinds of seasons.
One of our pastors, preached
a sermon last Sunday
and she focused on Psalm 23
and the particular verse
when the Psalmist says,
David in particular, "Yea,
though I walk through the valley
of the shadow of death,
I will fear no evil:
for thou art with me",
that confidence that the writer exhibits,
that audacity is shaped
by an experience with God,
for thou art with me and I
think at the end of the day,
for believers who find themselves
dealing with mental health challenges,
we cannot forget the presence of God
because it is through God I
think, that resources emerge,
it is through God that
opportunities come to the forefront
and it is also through God that
new and innovative pathways
towards healing and
wholeness become visible.
So those contradictions are not final,
the best is yet to come
and it does not appear what we shall be
when we trust that we're being
led and guided and directed
by a God who at the end of
the day, wants to see us
be the best versions of ourselves.
- Wow, so powerful, so well said.
I mean, I'm in...
well, I'm just in awe of just everything
that we've gone through
and even what's happened
in this last hour during our conversation
and what's been happening over
the years at the HOPE Center
and grateful, grateful for the trust
that you all have put
in God and one another
to be able to walk in
relationship like Dr. Green said
in a lot of ways
and walk in relationship
with those in your community,
I think that's, it goes a long way
and I'm sure that it's
important to the community
and acknowledged, even in
times when it's challenging.
So that gives me hope just
even hearing this story today
and these stories that you all shared,
so thank you so much,
Pastor Mike, Dr. Green
and Dr. Kinghorn for jumping
on the "Addy Hour" podcast,
I know this will be one of those
that people are going to be
able to go back and listen to
and I appreciate the way
you've spoken so poignantly
to our listeners as well and
have been so real and honest
at the same time.
- Well, thank you for having
me and thank for having us,
this has been great and I'm
grateful for the opportunity
just to share and be part
of this conversation.
- Thank you so much.
- Well, great being with all of you
and for all of our listeners, stay tuned
for some upcoming episodes
of the "Addy Hour"
and continue just like we
did today, to really dig deep
into some of these topics
and really have real
and honest conversations
that I think can empower
us and encourage us all.
So until next time.
(bright upbeat music)